- Bing with AI is gonna completely change
what people can expect from search.
We are grounded in the fact
that Google dominates this space.
I feel like a new race is starting
with a complete new platform technology.
I'm excited for the users
to have choice finally
and a real competitive race out there.
- [Joanna] Microsoft CEO Satya Nadella
finally thinks he has what
it takes to make Bing happen
and grab some search engine
market share from Google.
His not so secret weapon?
- This all started with us
an OpenAI coming together
with really a research agenda
on moving the state-of-the-art
of AI forward.
- [Joanna] Microsoft is taking
OpenAI's newest artificial
intelligence model
and intertwining it
with Bing's search data
so you can chat with the search engine
and get up to date information.
- So the entire point of ChatGPT early on
was to just sort of show
the power of the large model
and the conversational intelligence.
We now have not only
the current information
that you usually expect
from a search engine,
but you can then have a full conversation
around that current information
and all the other
information that came before.
- On top of the new AI
chat features in Bing,
Microsoft is adding ChatGPT-like features
to its Edge browser, so I came here
to Microsoft's headquarters
in Redmond, Washington
to get a hands-on demo of the new tools
and hear Nadell's thoughts on AI.
(mouse clicks)
The first big new feature,
Bing Chat.
Incorporated right into
the front page of Bing
will be an "ask me anything" box.
Type in your query, say,
the biggest winners of the 2023 Grammys,
because I did not have time to watch it.
And up pops your usual search results,
which Nadella says has
also been improved with AI.
But more interesting is this new chat box
that will start typing out
an answer to the question.
As it answers it also includes citations
so you know where the
information is coming from.
- It allows me to then
have a full-on conversation
around all the search data.
So yes, it's annotated,
it's about being able
to create even the links
back to all the publishers,
so this is just search, just better.
- The system took about a minute
to return a list of
the top Grammy winners.
Not exactly fast, but you can
tell it to stop responding.
Then you can ask follow up questions like,
do you know if Beyonce is touring?
- Perfect.
- If you're a Beyonce fan,
you might wanna hurry
and get your tickets before they're gone.
Like ChatGPT,
you can ask it non-search
type things too, like,
write 10 questions
for Satya Nadella
about AI.
(keyboard clicks)
What are the key features and benefits
of New Bing Chat mode, and
how does it leverage AI
to enhance the user experience?
- It really is grounded in search results
and helps me have a very contextual chat
or to be able to get to the right answers.
- Satya Bing said or AI Satya said,
"The New Bing chat mode leverages AI
"to understand the
user's intent, context,"
you said context,
"and preferences to
provide relevant visual,
"logical, and actionable responses."
- I love the AI Satya.
- [Joanna] But while these may seem
like fun and games in these demos,
there are of course real
misuses of this technology.
- We have a lot of practice
in thinking about safety.
AI is only good if it is
being used in the real world,
understanding, learning human preferences,
and our intent is to do that,
which is to put stuff
out there with safety,
but at the same time realizing
that we are going to have
to think about safety
as an ongoing responsibility,
not a one-time responsibility.
- He also told me there
are guardrails in place
to prevent harmful content,
hate speech, and more.
(mouse clicks)
The second big feature,
Microsoft Edge integration.
The Microsoft Edge browser
will now have a Bing sidebar
where you can ask it to
summarize a webpage you're on
or ask it to generate text.
For instance, I asked it to,
so I wanna write a letter to Satya Nadella
thanking him for his time.
Then I was able to tell
it I wanted it written
in an enthusiastic tone
in email form and short.
(keyboard clicks)
It knows.
- That's pretty good.
There's a lot of fear that
AI is gonna take our jobs,
replace us.
Is that unfounded and how
do you think about tools
like Bing now and how we
use it in the job market?
- Like, I think of this as
at the foundational level
going to help us do our jobs better,
reduce some of the drudgery
in some of our jobs,
whether it's in coding or in writing
or in automating a workflow
or searching for information.
So at the fundamental level,
I think we need a productivity boost.
I feel it'll create more jobs.
The barriers to knowledge
work will come down.
So, I mean, the unintended consequences
around labor market shifts
are always something
we need to be mindful
of, but I don't subscribe
to this zero sum or one
lump of labor fallacy,
and I think that we are going
to have new jobs get created
and more job opportunities.
- And it sounds like more time, right?
- For sure, for sure.
- We outsource some of this.
So I outsourced some of my
question writing to this.
It freed up a little bit more of my time
to do something else.
- And, but you are still in
the loop and you're in charge
because you get to accept the draft.
That's kind of one of
the metaphors I have,
is pretty much all computer
interaction going forward,
you'll start with a draft.
That doesn't mean you don't
get to inspect the draft
or proof the draft and
redefine and edit the draft.
- The question is,
which company will
write that draft for us?
Will it be Microsoft with tools like this,
or Google, which owns 90% of
the search engine market share,
and, right before my
interview with Mr. Nadella,
announced Bard, its
similar AI chat feature
that will come to its own search engine?
How are you thinking
about monetizing this?
- The last time I checked
software, I mean, it's a search
was the most profitable category
there is on planet Earth,
so therefore all I need
is a few more users,
and someone else that I'm competing in
has to keep all of their users
and all of their gross margin, right?
So I love, I'm looking forward to that.
- So no plans to charge for New Bing.
It's really advertising
model all the way through.
- We'll start there and
if there are other models,
there may be other models,
but there is enough surplus,
let me put it this way,
there is so much surplus
that goes to one place
which I think would be nice
if it was evenly distributed.
- What about Microsoft Office?
- Just stay tuned.
I fully expect us and to
introduce these capabilities,
quite frankly, across the
length and breadth of Microsoft.
- What about this guy?
- Oh, you know, it's sort
of like it was early,
and so we get to redefine
it for the AI age
and it's gonna be very useful.
- So is he coming back?
- He'll come back in a
variety of different ways.
I think I'm most excited about Bing
as the real incarnation of Clippy.
- Okay, but no actual, like, popup?
- I think we have much
better design mechanisms
to do what Clippy aspired
to do back in the day.
- Does Clippy haunt your dreams?
- Not really.
It's probably the thing that
was the most fun character
Microsoft introduced, which, you know,
think about it, right?
We have been on a 30-year
journey to perfect it,
so I'm excited to be here in
2023 launching Bing with AI.
(upbeat music)